des toits verts, ou agriculture urbaine.
Nous sommes familiers avec l'image à gauche qui montre
un jardin de quartier local dans South End.
C'est chez moi. J'ai une ruche dans le jardin.
Et peut-être un toit vert dans le futur,
quand nous utiliserons plus les zones urbaines,
où il y a des tas de jardins.
Regardez cette image au-dessus de la ligne orange à Boston.
Essayez de repérer la ruche. Elle est là.
Elle est sur le toit, dans le coin là-bas
et elle y est depuis deux ou trois ans maintenant.
La façon dont l'apiculture urbaine fonctionne actuellement
est que les ruches sont bien cachées,
et ce n'est pas parce qu'elles doivent l'être.
C'est juste parce que l'idée met les gens mal à l'aise,
et c'est pourquoi je veux aujourd'hui que vous essayez d'y réfléchir,
réfléchir aux avantages des abeilles dans les villes
et pourquoi elles sont vraiment formidables.
Permettez-moi de vous donner un bref aperçu de comment fonctionne la pollinisation .
Nous savons que les fleurs, les fruits et légumes,
même la luzerne dans le foin du bétail
que nous élevons pour la viande, dépendent des pollinisateurs,
mais vous avez des parties mâles et femelles sur une plante ici,
et en gros les pollinisateurs sont attirés par les plantes
pour leur nectar et dans la foulée,
une abeille va visiter quelques fleurs et ramasser du pollen,
ou ce genre d'homologue de sperme mâle,
et puis va sur des fleurs différentes et au final
une pomme, dans ce cas, sera produite.
Vous voyez l'orientation. La tige est vers le bas.
Le bout de floraison est tombé au moment où nous la mangeons
mais c'est une vue d'ensemble du fonctionnement de la pollinisation.
Et pensons à la vie urbaine, pas aujourd'hui,
ni dans le passé, mais qu'en sera-t-il dans une centaine d'années ?
A quoi va-t-elle ressembler ? Nous avons d'énormes problèmes
de perte d'habitat de nos jours. Nous avons de plus en plus de gens,
des milliards de personnes, dans 100 ans, Dieu sait combien de gens,
et le peu d'espace qu'il y aura pour les accueillir tous,
il nous faut donc changer la manière dont nous voyons des villes, et
en regardant cette photo à gauche de la ville de New York aujourd'hui,
vous pouvez voir comme elle est grise et brune.
Nous avons du papier goudronné sur tous les toits qui réfléchis la chaleur
dans l'atmosphère,
et contribue aux changements climatiques, sans aucun doute.
Qu'en sera-t-il dans 100 ans, si nous avons des toits verts
partout et du jardinage et nous créons nos propres cultures
dans les villes ? Nous économisons sur les coûts de transport,
nous économisons sur une alimentation plus saine, et nous éduquons également
et créons des emplois localement.
Nous avons besoin des abeilles pour l'avenir de nos villes et de la vie urbaine.
Voici quelques données que nous avons recueillies dans le cadre de notre entreprise
avec Best Bees, où nous livrons, installons et gérons
des ruches d'abeilles pour tous ceux qui le veulent,
en ville, à la campagne, et nous introduisons des abeilles,
et l'idée de l'apiculture dans votre arrière-cour ou sur votre toit
voire même sur votre escalier de secours,
et on voit comme c'est simple et comment c'est possible.
Il y a une tendance paradoxale que nous avons remarquée
dans ces chiffres. Voyons donc la première mesure ici,
la survie hivernale.
C'est un énorme problème depuis des années,
essentiellement depuis la fin des années 1980, quand l'acarien varroa est arrivé
et a apporté de nombreux virus différents, des bactéries
et des maladies fongiques.
Survivre à l'hiver est difficile,
et c'est là que la plupart des colonies sont perdues,
et nous avons constaté que dans les villes, les abeilles survivent
mieux qu'à la campagne.
Un peu paradoxal, non ?
Nous pensons, oh, abeilles, campagne, agriculture,
mais ce n'est pas ce que les abeilles manifestent.
Les abeilles se plaisent dans la ville. (Rires)
En outre, elles produisent également plus de miel.
Le miel urbain est délicieux.
Les abeilles de Boston sur le toit de l'hôtel Seaport,
où nous avons des centaines de milliers d'abeilles
qui le survolent en ce moment,
et je suis certain qu'aucun de vous ne les a remarquées en passant devant,
vont dans tous les jardins municipaux
et produisent un miel délicieux et sain
qui a le goût des fleurs de notre ville.
Donc le rendement des ruches urbaines, en termes de production de miel,
est plus élevé de même que la survie hivernale,
par rapport aux zones rurales.
Encore une fois, un peu paradoxal.
Et avec le recul historique sur la chronologie
de la santé des abeilles, nous pouvons revenir à l'année 950 et voir
qu'il y a eu une importante mortalité d'abeilles en Irlande.
Les problèmes des abeilles aujourd'hui ne sont pas nécessairement
quelque chose de nouveau. Ça se passe
depuis plus de mille ans
mais ce que nous ne remarquons pas vraiment ce sont ces problèmes dans les villes.
Je tiens donc à vous encourager à réfléchir
à l'idée de ce qu'est un îlot urbain.
Vous pensez peut-être que dans la ville la température est plus chaude.
Pourquoi les abeilles sont-elles mieux dans la ville ?
C'est une grande question pour nous aider à comprendre
pourquoi elles devraient être dans la ville.
Il y a peut-être plus de pollen dans la ville.
Avec les trains qui viennent dans les centres urbains, ils peuvent
transporter du pollen, du pollen très léger,
et c'est un grand supermarché dans la ville.
Beaucoup de tilleuls vivent le long de la voie ferrée.
Il y a peut-être moins de pesticides dans les villes
qu'il y en a dans les zones urbaines.
Il y a peut-être d'autres choses auxquelles nous ne pensons pas encore,
mais c'est une idée à laquelle réfléchir, les îlots urbains.
Et l'effondrement de colonie n'est pas la seule chose
qui affecte les abeilles. Les abeilles sont en train de mourir,
et c'est un problème énorme de notre époque.
Ce que vous voyez ici est une carte du monde,
et nous allons suivre la propagation de cet acarien varroa.
L'acarien varroa est ce qui a changé la donne
dans l'apiculture et vous pouvez le voir, en haut à droite,
les années changent, nous arrivons à l'époque moderne,
et vous pouvez voir la propagation de l'acarien varroa
depuis le début des années 1900 à maintenant.
C'est en 1968, et nous couvrons assez bien l'Asie.
En 1971, nous l’avons vu se répandre en Europe et en Amérique du Sud,
et puis, quand nous arrivons à 1980,
et plus précisément à 1987, l'acarien varroa est enfin arrivé
en Amérique du Nord et aux États-Unis,
et c'est là que la donne a changé
pour les abeilles domestiques aux États-Unis.
Bon nombre d'entre nous se souviennent de notre enfance,
peut-être avez-vous été piqué par une abeille, vous avez vu des abeilles sur les fleurs.
Pensez aux enfants aujourd'hui. Leur enfance est un peu différente.
Ils ne vivent pas ça.
Les abeilles ne sont tout bonnement plus là.
Nous avons besoin des abeilles et elles sont en train de disparaître et c'est un gros problème.
Que pouvons-nous y faire ?
Donc, je fais des recherches sur les abeilles.
J'ai obtenu mon doctorat en étudiant la santé des abeilles.
J'ai commencé à étudier les abeilles en 2005.
En 2006, les abeilles ont commencé à disparaître,
si soudainement, et ce petit gamin studieux
qui allait à l'école et travaillait sur les insectes (Rires)
est devenu très utile dans ce monde.
Et ça a fonctionné de cette façon.
Donc ma recherche se concentre sur les moyens de rendre les abeilles en meilleure santé.
Je ne recherche pas ce qui tue les abeilles, en soi.
Je ne suis pas un des nombreux chercheurs partout dans le monde
qui se penche sur les effets des pesticides ou des maladies
ou la perte d'habitat et la mauvaise nutrition chez les abeilles.
Nous examinons les moyens de rendre les abeilles en meilleure santé.
grâce à des vaccins, par le biais du yaourt, comme les probiotiques,
et d'autres sortes de thérapies qu'on puisse administrer aux abeilles par voie orale,
et ce processus est tellement facile, que même un enfant de 7 ans peut le faire.
Vous mélangez simplement du pollen, du sucre et de l'eau,
et tout ingrédient actif que vous souhaitez y mettre,
et vous le donnez aux abeilles. Aucun produit chimique,
simplement des intensificateurs d'immunité.
Nous les humains pensons à notre propre santé de façon prospective.
Nous faisons de l'exercice, nous mangeons sain, nous prenons des vitamines.
Pourquoi ne pensons-nous pas aux abeilles de la même façon ?
Implantons-les dans les zones où elles se développent
et essayons de les rendre plus saines avant qu'elles ne tombent malades.
J'ai passé plusieurs années d'études à tenter de piquer des abeilles et faire des vaccins
avec des aiguilles. (Rires)
Des années sur le banc, « Oh mon Dieu, il est 3 heures du matin
et je suis encore là à piquer des abeilles ». (Rires)
Et puis un jour, j'ai dit, « Pourquoi ne pas juste faire un vaccin oral ? »
Je me suis dit « Ouf » c'est ce que nous faisons. (Rires)
J'aimerais vous montrer quelques images des ruches urbaines,
parce qu'elles peuvent être n'importe quoi.
Je veux dire, soyez ouvert à ça.
Vous pouvez peindre une ruche assortie à votre maison.
Vous pouvez cacher une ruche à l'intérieur de votre maison.
Voici trois ruches sur le toit
de l'hôtel Fairmont Copley Plaza,
et elles sont magnifiques. Je veux dire, nous les avons assorties
à la nouvelle couleur de l'intérieur des chambres pour faire
un genre de bois colorés avec du bleu pour les draps,
et ces abeilles sont fantastiques et elles vont également se servir
des herbes qui poussent dans le jardin.
C'est ce que les chefs vont utiliser pour la cuisine,
et le miel, ils font des démonstrations devant vous,
ils utiliseront ce miel dans leurs bars.
Le miel est un substitut nutritionnel excellent du sucre ordinaire
parce qu'il y a différents types de sucres dedans.
Nous avons également un projet de ruches en classe,
où (c'est une entreprise à but non lucratif )
nous faisons passer le mot dans le monde entier pour dire comment
les ruches d'abeilles peuvent être amenées dans la salle de classe
ou dans le cadre du Musée, derrière une vitre,
et utilisées en tant qu'outil éducatif.
Cette ruche que vous voyez ici se trouve
à Fenway High School depuis de nombreuses années maintenant.
Les abeilles volent tout droit dans le champ du Fenway Park.
Personne ne le remarque. Si vous n'êtes pas une fleur,
ces abeilles ne se soucient pas de vous. (Rires)
Non. Vous ne les intéressez pas. Elles vous le disent,
« Pardon, je vole. » (Rires)
D'autres images ici qui racontent une partie de l'histoire
qui a vraiment rendu l'apiculture urbaine formidable, c'est
que dans la ville de New York, l'apiculture était illégale jusqu'en 2010.
C'est un gros problème : qu'est-ce qui va polliniser
tous les jardins et les produits localement ? Faut-il le faire à la main ?
Je veux dire, localement à Boston, il y a une entreprise formidable
appelée Green City Growers, et ils vont
polliniser leurs récoltes de courges à la main avec des cotons-tiges,
et s’ils ratent cette fenêtre de trois jours, il n'y a aucun fruit.
Leurs clients ne sont pas contents, et les gens ont faim.
C'est donc important.
Nous avons aussi quelques images de miel de Brooklyn.
C'était un mystère dans le New York Times
car le miel était très rouge et
le Département de médecine légale de l'état de New York est venu,
ils ont fait des analyses et ils ont trouvé que ça venait
du colorant rouge utilisé
dans une usine de cerise au marasquin au bout de la rue. (Rires)
Vous pouvez donc adapter votre miel au goût que vous souhaitez
en plantant des fleurs qui attirent les abeilles.
Paris est un modèle formidable pour l'apiculture urbaine.
Ils ont des ruches sur le toit de leur opéra
depuis de nombreuses années, et c'est ce qui a poussé les gens à penser,
« Ouah, nous pouvons le faire et nous devrions le faire. »
A Londres et en Europe aussi, dans l'ensemble,
ils sont très avancés dans l'utilisation des toits verts
et dans l'intégration des ruches,
et je vais vous montrer une note de fin.
Je tiens à vous encourager à ouvrir votre esprit.
Que pouvez-vous faire pour sauver les abeilles ou pour les aider
ou pour penser à l'avenir des villes durables ?
Oui, vraiment, changez simplement votre point de vue.
Essayez de comprendre que les abeilles sont très importantes.
Une abeille ne va pas vous piquer si vous la voyez.
L'abeille meurt. Les abeilles meurent quand elles piquent,
donc elles ne veulent faire ni l'un ni l'autre. (Rires)
Il n'y a pas de raison de paniquer. Elles sont partout dans la ville.
Vous pouvez même avoir votre propre ruche si vous le souhaitez.
Des ressources formidables sont disponibles,
et il y a même des entreprises qui vous aideront à l'installer et vous épauleront
et il est important pour notre système d'éducation dans le monde
que les élèves en apprennent davantage sur l'agriculture dans le monde entier
comme cette petite fille, qui, encore une fois, ne se fait même pas piquer.
Merci. (Applaudissements)